I don’t think this video needs an introduction,
so first at the very bottom, this should come
as absolutely no surprise, we have the Battle
of Winterfell.
It’s hilarious that the epic climactic battle
of the entire series both has terrible and
visually disgusting action and a story with
abhorrent usage of plot armor in every single
nanosecond of screen time.
I could really go off and rail into the story
in depth about why it’s so bad, but I’ll
primarily touch on the action since I’ve
covered most story issues a lot in past videos.
Now the first main thing that’s been brought
up a lot is the visibility of the action.
I understand the creators wanted to creatively
show the long night as being very dark, but
you have to keep the audience in mind.
There are certain mechanics within storytelling
like unrealistic lighting that viewers naturally
accept, as long as it aids the viewing experience.
On a technicallity if you were to shoot in
these conditions, then yes, it would be pitch
black.
But that’s not how movies and shows operate.
Non-diegetic lighting, which is lighting that
doesn’t have a physical source within the
world, has become very commonplace and thus
viewers have become used to it.
So in dark environments when you don’t supply
enough non-diegetic lighting, it’s even
worse because it shatters the norm of lighting
dark settings.
Not to mention there being a lot of fog and
smoke that makes things even harder to see.
So that’s the visibility side of things
which still feels a bit rough even with the
extra lighting later on.
Then we have the action side of things.
To me, what makes action so entertaining is
complex and great choreography that shows
off the immense skill of the character at
hand.
In the Battle of Winterfell, there’s only
like two scenes in the entire episode that
have long-form choreography.
Almost everything is just quick-cut action
where we only linger on a character for a
few seconds as they cut through a couple wights.
In small doses, this is fine so that you can
instill a sense of chaos, but when most of
the action is like this, it becomes very tiring.
In large-scale battle sequences, you need
to follow a given character for a decent amount
of time so that the action is more comprehensible.
We can view the action from one continuing
perspective instead of quickly trying to cover
every single base.
Lots of large-scale action setpieces do this
and an example I’ll use is Helms Deep since
the creators already compared this battle
to that one, which is pretty sad.
You follow each given hero for a good chunk
of time as they’re met with certain obstacles
that they have to overcome.
This gives the action more depth and allows
the audience to become more attached to the
moment as they adore the brilliant choreography.
However, in The Battle of Winterfell, the
only two characters that got this were Arya
on the wall and Jon Snow’s oner trying to
get to Bran.
There are other small moments, but the battle
feels more like they put an emphasis on quantity
of moments over quality moments.
I think a perfect opportunity to have more
choreography would have been with the white
walkers entering Winterfell.
Because they have to go through the courtyard
which is where most of our characters are
located.
So having a fight between some of them at
least would have been a major help to the
overall action quality.
Instead of them being pinned against a wall
perpetually surrounded by Wights where they
should have died a dozen times.
So even the presentation of the action destroys
any suspension of disbelief because they are
always in scenarios where they should have
died.
So overall, those major action issues with
other story issues like the brainless Dothraki
charge, the terrible defensive layout putting
the trebuchets in the middle of your army
with no additional trenches, and the death
of the Night King makes this my least favorite
battle in Game of Thrones.
It’s really depressing.
I’d love to do a scene-by-scene breakdown
and go into all of the numerous issues that
I didn’t have time to dive into, but we
need to get going.
Second from the bottom, we have the fall of
Kingslanding.
Now the special effects and the spectacle
within this battle are honestly pretty great.
It’s really just the story that absolutely
craters what chances of enjoyment I would
have had within this battle sequence.
Because if the story wasn’t completely braindead
then I’d probably really enjoy this battle.
However, that isn’t the case and the massive
elephant in the room is Dany’s turn.
I’ve already explained in many videos about
why her arc was butchered here, the most recent
one being the Top 10 most ruined characters,
so I don’t want to spend a lot of time going
over that again.
Outside of Dany’s arc there’s your usual
flair of contrived writing and plot armor.
The contrived aspect that really drives me
up a wall whenever I rewatch this episode
is the fact that the scorpions turn into incompetent
weapons being manned by people who are mentally
AFK.
And I’m not talking about Dany destroying
the fleet which is a whole other issue since
there’s like a hundred ships and she could
barely handle less than a dozen the episode
before, but the entire city’s defenses not
even moving to shoot at her is unacceptable.
When previously in the story you make it to
where a manned scorpion has the range and
accuracy of a world-class sniper, you then
can’t make them comically ineffective.
It just screams contriveness.
Then there’s the other dumb points like
Arya dying multiple times and Euron teleporting
to Jaime’s exact position in space and time.
So it’s not just Daenyers snapping which
is what a lot of people assume what’s wrong
with this battle.
Instead, it’s a constant stream of dumb
writing beats that sink this battle lower
and lower.
Then I said the spectacle was pretty great,
but the action within the spectacle is really
nothing special and is at times pretty bad.
Like the fight between Jaime and Euron is
flat out jarring and even has a moment that
breaks continuity.
On top of there not really being any other
fight scenes besides The Mountain vs. the
hound which is really the only saving grace
of this battle sequence.
So in essence, there may be some gorgeous
spectacle within this battle that can wow
you, but it feels weightless because of how
much its robbed by the writing.
At number 8 we have the Siege of Mereen.
Initially, I wasn’t even thinking about
counting this as a battle because of how fast
and anticlimactic it was, but it technically
counts.
It’s pretty crazy that this battle is smooshed
into the Battle of the Bastards episode.
Like you can really tell how fast David and
Dan are rushing to try and resolve everything
in Mereen so that Dany can head to Westeros.
If anything, it feels like this battle should
have had at least half of an episode on its
own because it’s literally the climax of
a plotline that lasted almost three seasons.
Let that sink in.
David and Dan resolved this major climactic
point in less than 10 minutes.
This is probably the biggest example of rushing
along the story.
Now from a technical standpoint, Dany can
easily smash the masters because she has dragons
and two separate large armies.
So you may be thinking, well Supercuts Delight
the battle is so fast because Daenerys made
slight work of taking out the masters, but
why the hell would the masters do this then.
They’re yielding magnificent results by
just using the Sons of the Harpy to cause
mass unrest within Mereen.
Like Tyrion genuinely didn’t know how to
stop what was happening.
As you can see in the beginning of season
6, Mereen is basically a ghost town entrenched
in misery and fear.
The second the Masters withdraw the Sons of
the Harpy, Mereen instantly explodes with
life and social prosperity.
So the question stands in that why would the
Masters not continue doing this and watch
the city slowly die and wither away.
Especially since they know that Daenerys will
be leaving to Westeros soon, which is also
confusing as to why they destroyed her fleet.
And instead, they decide to use the Sons of
the Harpy, who are just regular people with
no fighting experience, as a full-force army
to take over the city.
So David and Dan are essentially jerry-rigging
the story into a nonsensical direction so
that it can quickly end and Dany can move
on without any burdens.
Because unsurprisingly, the Sons of the Harpy
are quickly snuffed out by Dany’s army and
she uses her dragons to instantly make them
surrender.
Watching her torch a ship with her three dragons
is a satisfying moment with some payoff, but
that’s really the only positive aspect of
this entire sequence.
The only reason why I wouldn’t put this
lower in the battle ranking is because the
writing doesn’t infuriate me as much as
The Battle of Winterfell and the Fall of Kingslanding.
It's just here and blending into the corner
as you forget about it since The Battle of
the Bastards is much more memorable and overshadows
it completely.
For number 7 we have the Iron Fleet surprise
attack.
This is again another small battle that I
would count because of it’s large scale
and it’s an actual scene.
Unlike the assault on Casterly Rock which
is essentially just a montage.
The main reason that I’m putting this battle
low on this list is because it’s really
short and there aren’t a ton of impressive
aspects about it.
It’s mostly generic quick cut action which
gets the job done.
Then there’s one satisfying choreographed
scene where Euron kills the sand snakes.
This feels kind of fan servicey because of
the fan hatred towards them, but it was still
good nonetheless.
In particular, I liked the variety in weapon
combat in terms of Euron countering the spear
and the whip.
Then there’s a few minor writing flaws like
Euron’s fleet being able to sneak up on
them so easily, and them kind of just leaving
Theon Greyjoy behind to live.
How generous of Euron to allow Theon the opportunity
to come back and save his sister.
Since this scene is 5 minutes there’s not
a ton to talk about so yeah.
Onto number 6 I’m kind of cheating a little
bit, but it’s the Battle of the Stepstones.
The video does say Game of Thrones but I’ll
rope in House of the Dragon just to see where
this battle ranks in comparison to the others.
This may seem relatively low, but keep in
mind it’s kind of hard to compete against
other battles that are much bigger and longer.
Because that’s the main downside to this
battle in that it only lasts for 3 minutes
excluding the Daemon rush.
Which going into that, I still see a lot of
people knock it for having plot armor and
I still stand by the fact that it’s believable.
The archers are very far away trying to hit
a target in full sprint, moving erratically,
and taking cover occasionally.
So the fact that he is hit with 3 arrows I
might add since people act like he doesn’t
get hit once, is fine.
With that out of the way I really like the
concept of Daemon doing an all out rush for
his life.
It’s infused with high adrenaline that is
severely aided by the fact that there’s
a lot of buildup to this moment.
Ramin Djwadi also helps the scene with his
haunting score that then explodes simultaneously
with the action.
I really love the progression of this scene
as he just barrels through people and eviscerates
them.
Makes him come across as such a badass and
thus makes him an even cooler character.
This paired with a short battle right after
I think at least puts this in the middle of
my ranking.
There are some shots with some wonky VFX like
the blood effects oddly looking bad, but like
usual, this battle hosts a lot of chaotic
energy.
It was cool though to see Lord Corlys rip
through people and gave the action another
fun perspective to follow in the mayhem.
At number 5 it’s the Spoils of War or The
Loot Train Attack.
Despite this battle taking place in a rather
bad season of the show, it still manages to
be pretty good.
It does have its flaws obviously, but it has
some high points for action.
The initial breach of Dany lighting up over
a dozen people with her Dragon is one of the
most iconic moments in any battle sequence.
It just hits you with an orgasmic rush of
satisfaction because we’ve been waiting
for this kind of moment for 6 seasons.
Along with the execution being brutal and
practical.
I’m really happy that most of the fire stunts
weren’t done digitally and it makes the
action so much more authentic.
Your jaw hits the floor because you’ve never
seen anything on this scale before.
Then for the Dothraki, the action has an interesting
dynamic because you see two completely different
styles of fighting clash together.
And a style that severely counters the other
as Robert Baratheon said.
We see some cool variety like Dothraki shooting
arrows from horseback, dual-wielding arakhs,
and their superior dexterity and speed as
they take down multiple Lannister soldiers
before dying.
I’ve also kind of skipped over it, but the
beginning of this battle is an outstanding
example of perfect buildup.
It first interrupts a normal dialogue scene
with a distant rumbling of horse hooves, to
the frantic realization that they are getting
rolled up on and they need to quickly form
a tangible defense, to the reveal of the massive
army coming over the horizon in which the
heroes realize they’re screwed, and then
the even bigger reveal of a dragon heading
right for them and it’s about to turn into
a bloodbath.
It’s literally a perfect escalation that
gets you really hyped and reminds me of the
opening battle in The Mummy which I adored
growing up.
Also in the build-up, I love the quick cuts
of Lannister soldiers shitting their pants.
It really allows us to sympathize with them
and how much fear they must be feeling.
Then from a technical standpoint, the battle
is really impressive to me because you have
to simultaneously juggle the ground assault
and the air assault.
I think the creators found a good balance
in terms of presenting the battle because
it could have been very incoherent.
It flows really well and even the quick moments
of action have more time to breathe and aren’t
just quickly thrown in to artificially make
the edit more chaotic.
Then one last thing about the action before
going into the writing side of things, I think
the oner with Bronn in the middle of the battlefield
was a great creative decision.
It geniusely shows us this uninterrupted hellish
experience of dragon warfare and allows the
audience to watch in horror as to how brutal
and crazy this must be to go through.
Like I’d even be scared to go through this
if I was fighting for Daenyers.
So for the writing, there are a few nitpicks
like why didn’t Dany do a strafe run down
the defensive line of Lannisters, and why
she destroyed the food instead of capturing
it, but those are pretty minor to me and the
ending is much worse in my opinion.
David and Dan simultaneously wanted to keep
Jaime Lannister alive, but they also wanted
him to be in the battle.
So getting him out alive just fundamentally
wouldn’t make sense and Bronn tackling him
into the water and miraculously swimming him
an entire lake distance away is ridiculous.
Not to mention that Jaime is wearing full-plated
armor.
It sucks that David and Dan couldn’t come
up with a better way to get around it.
Just thinking about it now, a significantly
better change would be to have Jaime become
traumatized by watching his men getting torched
and have him simply run away.
Then he can deal with the burden of abandoning
his post and the betrayal of his men, which
eats him alive internally.
This could also be a contributing factor for
him going North to fight for the living because
he wants to make amends for his cowardice
in the past.
Not him teleporting out of the battle so he
can artificially remain in the story.
So it’s pretty unfortunate that the ending
to this battle sucks because if that wasn’t
the case then I’d put it higher.
Onto number 4 we have The Battle of the Bastards.
Now this may seem like heresy putting what’s
regarded as the best battle in the show at
number 4, but hear me out.
If it was just from the perspective of action
then this battle would definitely be higher.
However, you have to also consider the story
side of things because that aspect drags this
battle down like Jaime sinking to the bottom
of the lake.
There’s sadly so many aspects wrong with
this like one of the main ones being Sansa
not telling Jon about the vale which would
have led to an easy winning strategy of having
much higher numbers.
Then another thing about this that people
don’t consider is that if Sansa confirmed
earlier that she had their support, then most
of the other northern houses who were hesitant
to join, most likely would have.
Which would increase their chances of winning
even more.
Instead, David and Dan create a contrived
sense of an underdog conflict for more drama.
The Vale magically arrive at the exact moment
of Jon’s defeat and this may be a nitpick,
but how would this large army even be a surprise
to the Boltons.
Is there no such thing anymore as scouts reporting
on enemy movements?
Like what happened to the times in the earlier
seasons where Tywin and Rob would get constant
reports on one another's armies.
Hell, even Brienne escorting Jaime across
the country got spotted by a random peasant.
But now?
Armies are teleporting around with literally
no strategic or geographical depth.
Then there’s your obvious instances of plot
armor of Jon becoming a god and surviving
dozens of barrages and cavalry charges.
With this critique, I’m not saying that
I want him to die, but instead I want him
to sustain some kind of injury because if
he can survive this, then you ruin the realism
and sense of danger that were set in the earlier
seasons.
There are some other minor issues like Wun
Wun basically going into the war naked and
with no weapons, the mostly idiotic military
strategy, there not really being any characters
on the villain side fighting that you care
about, within 2 minutes of the battle there
are massive piles of bodies, along with it
being confusing as to why it’s so condensed
when everyone is spread out, and people who
don’t understand the concept of not running
in a straight line.
But heyyyy, now that we got past that massive
tsunami of dogshit, we can finally appreciate
the gorgeous action on display.
Because really everything is firing on all
cylinders.
The cinematography is breathtaking and establishes
some of the most iconic shots in the entire
series of Jon facing down an entire cavalry
charge, the juxtaposing singles of Jon and
Ramsey, the POV of an arrow barrage, the insane
oner with clever ways of hiding cuts in the
chaos, and a brilliant top down shot of jon
remerging as if he’s being reborn.
Drawing genius parallels to Dany’s ending
in season 3.
Fun fact, this moment wasn’t actually planned
and was something that Miguel Sapochnik came
up with the night before shooting.
I also love the bleak, dour, and cold color
correction for the overall episode.
Looking specifically at the action, I think
it’s a good combination of frantic cuts
with quick action supplemented with Jon’s
legendary oner.
It’d be nice if this section of the battle
was a bit longer and we could see how Jon
was surviving this chaos more, but it’s
still great nonetheless.
The overall production value and what they
were able to achieve with an 11 million dollar
budget is insanely impressive.
This has become a golden standard of excellent
VFX integrated with practical elements.
If I were to pause this frame you probably
wouldn’t be able to tell what’s real and
fake.
But yeah, the entire battle is amazing from
an action perspective and it’s really sad
that it gets held back by the shoddy writing.
At number 3 we have Hardhome.
Unlike battles before this, I honestly can’t
think of any big flaws that deteriorate my
enjoyment of this.
It completely comes out of nowhere and the
pure excitement you feel from being this surprised
by a sudden battle was truly a special experience.
It absolutely floors you as all of the characters
are left extremely vulnerable.
Miguel Sapachonik perfectly captures the panic
and hysteria of people being terrified and
I think hiding the undead behind the wall
for a period of time adds to the horror buildup.
That and it acts as a good way to naturally
slow down the enemy so that they don’t immediately
destroy our characters.
Now the action is predominantly quick-cut
and fast-paced, but I think that’s much
more justified because this isn’t a battle,
it’s a massacre.
We do get some occasional choreographed moments
and in particular, I love the tracking shot
of Jon running through the battle and doing
a 360 chop on a wight.
We also get to see Wun Wun absolutely obliterate
his foes for the first time which is amazing
too.
Then besides most of this chaos we get a duel
between Jon and a white walker.
The introduction of the white walker in particular
was so badass and perfectly framed.
Along with it having thematic significance
of fire and ice.
But besides this opening shot, the white walker
destroying this seemingly powerful character
makes you think Jon is screwed for the fight.
And he pretty much is and kind of wins due
to a lucky instance in that he caught the
white walker off guard since he was expecting
his sword to shatter.
This paired with a handful of magnificent
moments like the undead barreling off the
cliff, Karsi getting rekt by wight children,
our heroes running together in unity with
that great trio shot, and the wall falling
down make this a consistently riveting action
setpiece.
Not to mention the best ending to any battle
sequence on this list being the iconic resurrection
scene.
So yeah, I came really close to putting this
battle at number 2, but I feel like the next
two have more to offer than Hardhome.
For Number 2 we have the Blackwater.
Before going into the action, I want to point
out how expertly crafted the buildup to this
battle was.
Because through the entire season, there’s
this constant dread in the air that Kinglsanding
will essentially be helpless if Stannis decides
to attack them outright.
Even leading right up to the battle there’s
this nauseating feeling of helplessness accentuated
by different characters.
Then it’s all relieved by an immensely clever
action made by Tyrion in blowing up Stannis’
fleet.
This adds to that euphoric rush of relieving
that defeated mentality, along with this moment
just being jaw-dropping from how impressive
the visuals and VFX are.
It kind of reminds me of the initial strafe
that Daenerys does, but this moment has way
more build-up and story significance.
This moment leads to a more triumphant feeling
and throughout the battle, there’s this
ebb and flow of going from a winning and losing
mentality.
Because even though this explosion evened
the odds a bit, there’s still a daunting
task in front of them as they still have another
half of Stannis’ army to repel.
This makes the battle story-wise feel a lot
more dynamic and unpredictable as to who you
think will win.
Even though Tywin is technically on the way.
Then for the action, there’s technically
not a lot of it and this is probably a bit
of a budgetary issue, but what they captured
was still good.
They infused it with enough quantity of carnage
to capture the essence of a crazy battle interspersed
with the Hound absolutely obliterating people.
I honestly could just watch that for hours.
The highlight of this battle to me however,
besides the explosion, is the great character
work.
Every major character here essentially has
an arc of sorts between the Hound finally
defecting and leaving, Joffrey wimping out
and showing how much of a coward he is, and
Tyrion rising to the occasion and becoming
the savior of Kingslanding.
Essentially dismantling all the hateful notions
people made towards him.
That kind of emotional rush for the character
is so moving that you can’t help but feel
incredibly excited.
There is some more character work with Sansa
and Cersei, but I honestly found that their
scenes hurt the pacing of the battle.
Their scenes are good, but an unfortunate
side effect is the antsy feeling of wanting
to get back to the action.
It kind of feels like these interjected scenes
were more of a way to pad out the length of
the battle because of the relatively small
budget.
Then the scale was still impressive with so
many wonderful wideshots of rushing the beach
and scaling the walls.
And heyyy, a character actually sustains some
kind of major injury and they didn’t even
make a complete blunder like Jon Snow.
It still pisses me off that he faces no consequences
for his mistake of falling into Ramsey’s
trap, but yeah, the Blackwater is an outstanding
battle and is the first time in which we get
to witness an action scene on this magnificent
scale.
Finally, at number 1 we have The Watchers
on the Wall.
This really shouldn’t be a surprise because
this was also my favorite episode.
The Watchers on the Wall is perfect from every
single aspect.
Whether it be scale, characters, action, choreography,
story beats, acting, dialogue, the great setting,
and cinematography.
It’s all flawless.
From a story perspective, the plot and characters
are incredibly investing because this has
been building up for multiple seasons.
There are so much emotional stakes charged
for each character whether that be for Ser
Alliser desperately defending his home and
not wanting to be the first to fall to Wildlings,
the conflicted nature of Rose in that she’s
angry at Jon but simultaneously still loves
him, or Jon being torn between killing these
wildlings that aren’t the enemy.
It just feels like a tragedy for him in that
he has to defend his brothers from people
who should be their allies.
So the story and characters in this battle
make every scene thoroughly engaging because
both sides are considered as the good guys.
This creates a lot more emotional and story
depth because the conflict isn’t black and
white.
It’s very complex and I like it more than
future battles that are essentially just good
versus evil.
Then of course the action is hard-peaking
here.
Like the iconic oner of the entire courtyard
and longer take duels between different characters.
The Watchers on the Wall is also really the
first and only battle when you think about
it that has character duels.
Where we have Tormund vs Ser Alliser and Jon
vs Styr.
The only other battles that has a character
duel is in The Bells between Jaimie and Euron
which is just yeah, and then Battle of the
Bastards where Tormund kills Smalljon who
really didn’t have any characterization.
And Jon killing Ramsay which was more of a
butchering.
I think character duels creates a great dynamic
in which you have stakes on both sides of
the action.
Like you kind of wanting Tormund and Alliser
to survive and for Jon to kill Styr.
Instead of the generic mowing down of random
unnamed enemies.
It actually creates an investment for this
action scene.
Then there are so many iconic moments like
a giant impaling someone with his bow and
arrow, dropping the scythe, a giant riding
a mammoth, and the boys coming together to
take down a big chongus.
It makes the battle consistently exciting
as it offers fresh and fun moments.
You can really tell that the budget is much
higher here than the Blackwater and makes
me wonder how much better that battle sequence
would have been with a bigger budget.
Because this battle just keeps you in a constant
state of amazement because the background
action is always dialed up to 11 and there
is so much VFX casually being used to great
effect.
Then this is something that probably isn’t
brought up a lot, but I think the pacing of
this battle is spectacular.
Because most battles start and are essentially
a full sprint to the finish, but the Watchers
on the Wall feels like a marathon.
There are a lot of great character beats planted
throughout this battle like Samwell becoming
more brave and even helping a scared Pip,
Jon and Sir Alliser’s delightful conversation,
and different characters getting to take charge.
Which essentially gives some cooldown time
between certain action beats.
That and the war speech from Sir Alliser is
fucking amazing and I just adore his character.
Also, I haven’t even touched on the tragic
ending of Jon losing Rose.
The battle ends with such a dramatic gut punch
and the convention break in which the creators
use slow motion for the first time was genius.
It links us into Jon’s headspace as we are
solely focused on his misery amongst the chaos
surrounding him.
I can really talk about this masterpiece of
a battle for like an hour and why it’s so
amazing, but yeah, for the sake of your time
I’ll end it here.
Thank you for watching and let me know in
the comments what your ranking would be.
I’m genuinely curious because I know a lot
of people’s favorite battle tends to be
the Battle of the Bastards and I’m curious
what you guys think.
And by the way, this video was voted on by
my patrons, have a good day.